Hello. This is the last day, and I must say you can start the tape now.
This is the last day and why there's so much I want to tell you. There's so little time and so on.
So I'm going to have to probably not say everything else that I said I've learned about tech in this last day.
First of all, to tell all business on reflection,
the I the solution to the right justification problem problem five yesterday that someone
suggested in class of changing carriage return to to be a type 13 character instead of type 12.
Probably I shouldn't have silenced it so quickly. It probably is a better solution.
And the one I had in fact tonight to redefine the paragraph four that way.
I don't know why it didn't strike me yesterday, as I think it's probably the better solution of the two alternatives.
When I finally write Appendix D, I'll check both out very carefully and see if I can think of any any bugs in them.
The other thing is nobody. Can we focus on this?
I want to mention a this is a certificate I present to our teaching assistant for his voluntary work for these these times and also.
OK, now we've I also have certificates like this for everyone who solves the challenge problem.
Ah, and in fact, there is one person has such a brilliant approach to the challenge problem that even if he didn't finish it by noon,
I'm going to give him a certificate. And then there was there were great solutions to the homework problems that were turned in yesterday.
I have to show you those, because these were these are these are not only solutions, but beautifully formatted and commented,
oh, you see, this is problem number one and it puts the solution and so on and then gives the put on the same page.
Problem number two, the the same thing really I put had to go on the next page.
Problem three and problem four and so on with all the things getting solved.
So this is a beautifully formatted document and combines these solutions with the outputs and everything.
So that also was it was very meaningful to me.
So I have made up some some official license's also for the for the perpetrators of that document.
And I said this is the problem I had with a door this morning when I first tried to print those licenses, it said it said no output.
Page one is too complex to print. I said, oh, no, what am I going to have to do?
Printed in sections and pasted together and. And it turned out it was the Stanford seal that I had that I intended to just
include underneath the gold seal that was making it too complex to print.
So so we just left off the Stanford seal and if that got him, it got simpler.
OK. And so there's a couple of other words. I'm running out of seal, so I hope there weren't too many solutions to the challenge problem.
Can you give this to Barbara?
Now, the the other things that I wanted to to mention were questions that people specifically said they would like to see discussed this week.
And one of them is about struts.
This is such an important topic.
I don't know why I didn't bring it up earlier, because it's really a basic to writing lots of macros that the idea of what what's become called a.
I think Terry Winogrand made up the name. Let me give you an example of of of a definition of a strut and then you can see what I mean.
We have this on the screen. A strut would be, for example, lower the ones that I used typically with ten point type on a twelve point base.
I would say lower three and a half points. Reebok's it's 12 points of nothing.
Now, what does this do? It makes a box that you can insert into a horizontal list that gets lowered.
Three and a half points and a box was just empty,
but it was twelve points high after it's been lowered as eight 1/2 points above the baseline and three and a half below the baseline.
This is typically the size then of a of a of a line of type.
If you're setting up twelve point lines so you have twelve point lines in each one,
you could consider having eight and a half from the top and three and a half to death.
Now this sum is useful primarily when you want to put boxes but boxes together,
you have some kind of a macro that built a V box and then you want to put another V box next to it.
See, according to the rules of V boxes and boxes in general,
we have only one reference point for the box, and it's the reference point of the last base line.
So if we built a V box out of all of lot of independent H boxes, TEC has forgotten where the base line was of the top line.
And and it doesn't have the data structure any room for more than three things about this box, the height, the depth and the weight.
So there would be, you know, if I wanted to add another component to it,
that would that would seriously comp complicated tax coding and and and usage of memory for all the simple cases.
But it does only have these three these three numbers for any box.
This is to be considered the baseline at the box. Here's another baseline. So now there are different ways to work with this.
There's the V, the V top and V center.
We'll take a box and center it or V top actually goes back and runs through and finds the top
baseline in the box and changes the baseline of the whole box to be the base in the top box.
So there is something in tech that will actually go and find the top baseline of a box that's only allowed in math mode.
But it's but you can always go to mass murder if you need it so that you can know if you want if you want to continue some text and then have a.
A box that that agrees on the top line and then has something sticking out underneath that you can do so with V top.
However, there are these other cases where you build, where you build a box, you build another box, and you want to put them together.
And it looks bad if you put both of them together and they just end up and it's just the height of the top box butting
against the depth of the bottom box on the top one because the baselines aren't exactly the same distance apart.
And so fortunately, there's a simple way to get tempted to make nice looking output even without even
without adding all this complexity to its internal memory usage and deselection.
That's a strike. If you if if it was. We assume that that that's our text is is not terribly exceptional in exceptional cases.
In fact, this will do the right thing also.
We put up we put a strike right at the very beginning of this top line here, and it struck right at the end of the paragraph.
If this was HD box five or something like that,
or at the end of the last line on the box and inside the box, the baselines will be twelve points apart.
Just this is correct. OK. Now, if you take two of these boxes and put them together with the line, skip to zero,
then even though the baselines are very far apart, I think we'll we'll we'll we'll put the boxes right next to each other.
And this is to avoid the problems of of of of two boxes.
Usually the height of this box would only be the height of the tallest letter in that line.
Sometimes you sometimes you just didn't use any any letters like B or D, and you had shorter letters in the box.
And it would make a difference. Similarly, the depth of the box that is depends on if you have any Y's or JS in the last line.
And that would affect the baseline Y. So we put the struts at the beginning and end.
So typically, if you're defining a macro for a user, that's going to be that's going to be used to combine box to combine boxes.
And these will be tacked, tacked on in each into a vertical column or something like that.
Insert yourself awestruck. And at the very beginning and first line, the end.
The very last line. And also doing an H a line, you will stick it straight in your preamble H line.
Well, like, if I'm defining a general macro for form for math package and I want to make a matrix and it turns
out that the matrix is done usually with a V center and then in an H line inside the V center,
it's good to put a stretch in here in each line just because otherwise you might have a matrix that has a and another one that has BBB.
And this one would come out a little different from this one.
So they'd be centered slightly differently. Parenthesis would be the same.
If you're lucky, if it doesn't come right at the boundary between one size parenthesis in the next size.
But this boxes would be set. It would be different sizes. If you didn't have those invisible struts in there because the B is taller than an eight.
All right. So wise to put the two have to have invisible struts in in general purpose macros otherwise.
I mean, this is where that is where they appear. You don't. The user usually doesn't ever have to worry about him or see him.
Question is, what's the most efficient kind of a structure to insert?
Well, it isn't a primitive of tech, and it's possible that if these things proliferate,
we have room in a data structure to add a structure to the thing.
Right now, this creates a box in memory, takes up five or six words of memory, even though the box is empty.
For the record, the height, the depth and the width and the fact that it's not it's not it's glue set in the setting of the glue is is it is is zero,
but it's in every box, which you'd say what you say two words per strata if you made it a rule.
For example, if you made it a vertical rule, width zero and then height eight and a half point depth three and a half points, something like that.
That would also give the same effect because of a rule of what?
Zero doesn't print it just and it takes up a forewords attack that the structure doesn't have the room for the glue set.
And that's that it's longer it's a longer piece of text that tech will have to scan every time it sees the word strike.
But it's not that much slower that it would make a big difference if you were you wanted to minimize the amount of text referred to as stretched.
You would probably reserve a box and defined box eight, save, save, save eight or.
No, to be a to be a. Oh, an H.
Box that has this lowered V box in it and so on, that that actually is taking up more of tech memory.
But then you could say copy eight instead of straight. Every time you minimize the length of text that tech has to read in order to do every step.
But that's not really saving any time. It has to do the copy Operation Subroutine. That's ridiculous.
OK. There's different ways of different ways to get the struts in their main thing.
Idea of Australia's a invisible box that help that that gives you firm knowledge about the height of the top or the bottom of some of some boxes.
Another thing about backslid, that was my first topic that I wanted to mention here is somebody.
Well, the other thing is PR backslides PR. It's possible to match, you know, in a when you're defining a control sequence.
This control sequence backslash PR will match a blank line if you're you know, you you defining something and then you have no one terminated by PR.
This will be terminated by a blank line. Similarly, you can redefine P.
You can redefine PR. At one point you couldn't. But now you can redefine PR to be something else.
Even with parameters of the interesting and that will that will occur with whenever a blank line is sense.
Then this macro will get we'll get calls. If you if you really it.
Now of course if you want and you, you want some point to tell tech to end the paragraph.
And so before you redefine it, you'd better save. You'd better save something.
Text paragraph routine equals PR or else you can never be able to get out of horizontal mode.
So any way to get on a horizontal mode, you'd be stuck inside of braces another way.
It goes away at the end of us. At the end of a group through.
OK, now. Now the thing is someone asked about additional symbol fonts.
Well, one thing you can do in the middle of a math formula. You can have a dollar sign on and you can go in each box in the middle of that formula.
And here you can do a math. You can change math X.
You can. You can. You can, you know, get a new variable, delimiters if you want.
If you have two kinds of variable glimmers in the final, you can use them. You have to put you have to do.
You have to set that up. You know, math x some other font name for your delimiters.
Before you go into math mode, the the fonts that you're using are math fonts.
Ah ah ah. Save the way in, you know stack like, like the stacks for codes and so on at the time a dollar sign occurs.
And, and then in here I could, I could use square root and I would get a square root from the new, the new extension font.
Similarly, like the math Roman font could be changed.
You can specify, you know, the three three different sizes of back.
You could have X, Y, Z. For your math Roman fonts inside of this thing.
And then it would use different letters in that font.
And this is the way we for example, we're gonna have both old style numerals and and new style numerals.
And if somebody calls for old style numerals, then this would then he can just refer to numbers in here and they'll come out in the old style.
If the if the if their own phone has been changed in the middle of a formula,
while other numbers like you might want to put those old style numerals into a matrix or something like that.
So you could also switch to to a bold symbols find if you have a whole section of your family you wanted to be, to be bold.
We've never computer modern has these bold symbols funds, but nobody has ever has ever generated for the.
For their front libraries yet. But they're there.
And I tested them when I designed my coat. I think they'll come out okay. You could even have a bold mass extension from now the next.
The other thing is there was a little thing about H. Phil versus one L. Phil versus two airfields.
This one is an abbreviation for a stretch of plus 10 to the 5th points.
And this one is plus ten to the tenth points. So this is a strong amount of stretch and this is a very large amount of stretch.
But this is much larger. The effect of this is that that this one is like infinity squared.
And this is like infinity or if you prefer, this is infinity is the square root of infinity. But it's a.
Depends now if what you have if you have only H feels with one L.
In a formula, then they will act like fillers.
But if any H fills the two wells are in there, then all the H fills disappears in sort of our wiped out nothing.
And this is this has been used, for example, to the design macros where someone you can where you want to send or something.
You can put h fill around both sides of it or HSF also is of this order magnitude and somebody puts
an H fill in there that solves that's enough to override the thing for stretching or shrinking.
It wouldn't dunwich H assessment that that would. But this would put it.
So then that would allow somebody to to left justify something or write justify something inside of a macro that's normally center question on that.
You couldn't. Wow. Could not one have simply specified a glue of plus minus 10 to the points on the opposite side that you didn't want.
Yeah. Yeah. If somebody has if somebody has has put h filling inside so you can also put it h fill neg which is which cancer.
We don't have the negative of that one a as a permanent. But you can also write it in specifically tend to.
And H will make will cancel h fill in that will. And that's another thing, that's another way to do it.
The reason I'm asking the question is because you know,
person X finds markers will h fill the person Y calls of the wants the cream put uses h fill with two ls the person he
calls them wants the cream them it has to define it h for three ls pretty soon your numbers are getting pretty big.
But if you minus them out you could go indefinitely. Pretty much.
This is the R. That's right. In fact you three ls would would exceed the floating plant capacity colleague has somewhat.
We're going to start doing fixed point arithmetic later. Yeah. Then the negative cancelation are also also works in that way.
But this h feel it's on somehow more mnemonic if you're gonna have two levels.
And that's why for example when you write a fraction, if you write a H feel over B plus C, the internally TEC uses this kind of glue.
And so that's gonna come out A over B plus C like that.
Yeah. So. So you can use it in a math formula. And then I have user would just like to probably put an H feel there the.
And inside the it says has one L. That's right.
If we're gonna have to get in hierarch or eat, everybody's fooling everybody else, then they have to cooperate a little more.
And designing this site on something either either to use tend to the third or something else.
With Kent, with negative cancelations, I'm with you, I think negative things aren't that aren't that complex.
But a lot of other people are are are afraid of negative numbers.
And I think most of the you know, like my my daughter's teacher in my daughter's math teacher right now.
Now, see the challenge problem I have. I've got I received one one solution here.
I haven't seen how we did it. Let me see you do it with Bart insert, apparently.
OK. Well anyway, now, now I. I know of three solutions to this challenge problem.
Three different approaches. And one of the one of the.
Oh OK. The main idea in all of these three solutions is given by the first line of the challenge solution.
Can we pass that out please?
The first line of the challenge solution which says this is that this is just a solution that I had when I made up the hand.
I can we have it on the screen, please? The V size V, size eight and a half point.
That was the that was the key to all of these methods, saying that that every time a line comes out,
it's going to go to the output routine and in the outer routine, it's going to save it away and make a real pages somehow some other way.
OK, well, that's the first step in the solution, but that's not all.
You also have to figure out how to get the information to the page. Thing about what what you look like to stick in the margin.
And so there were three solutions. Well, by the way, the top baseline and max depth,
I can go with that six essentially saying that that one line at a time we'd
like to top baseline to be positioned so that each time I put put out a page,
it's going to be the first line on that page will be eight and a half points from the top.
Now that the the three solutions, one of them was to use marks to put out a mark every time the three time he got to a new verse,
because that mark is something that stays with the. That's gap that can go to the operating output routine, can read marks.
No problem with that solution is that if you try to use Mark's, you get an error message saying you can't do that in horizontal mode.
All right. And however, next week, you will be able to do that in horizontal mode.
I found out that I found out that with only three lines that changed three lines of the tech program.
It'll work beautifully. And all it all the instructions were there.
And I know it's not going to mess up anybody's existing program because because they would have gotten an error if they tried it now.
So. So they knew. So tech will allow marks in horizontal mode from now on.
And these marks will just stick very inside the paragraph. And whatever line they happen to appear on, the mark will appear.
Right. Right. Following that line. Merely following that line.
Just as the way inserts do and sends don't get get oh ejects also page page.
But the page break and eject get get disappear out of the box of the line and end up and go back into the, into the following, into the vertical list.
Right after that each box. So Marks will work next week.
And that's very nice because Mark is a way to communicate lots of things to the outlook routine.
Now that's something I should mention also. When you say, Mark, in the ordinary sense of the operating and you give some text here,
the original intention of that was that this would convey one one piece of information to the author routine.
The other routine could have top marks on bottom and so on.
Now, the question is,
what if you have two things you wanted to tell the author routine and it wants to use one of them in one place and one of them in another place?
Well, my first solution to that problem was very Harry, but I didn't.
And I and I didn't know how to generalize it very well to three, but I used to send a mark,
which would be either T followed by something or F followed by something.
And then I would call a mark with an F test in front of it and it would select I guess it also had the else in there.
And then Mark would come in this kind of fashion and then it would have to piece
of information and then I could call it getting getting one or the other.
But that was very clergy. But there's such a simple way to come to to give to give it as much information as you want in these marks.
Just by saying, like g def g def m a to be the first kind of thing and then g m b to be.
The next and JDF, FMC to be the next, and then in the output routine,
you simply execute your top mark marker or first mark, whichever one or all three of them.
And at first you'd execute maybe top Mark and then you'd save away M.A and be NMC in some other control sequences and you'd execute first Mark.
And then you could have all the all the nine pieces of information, say if there were MVC and M,
A and B and every mark and then the output routine would be able to use all nine piece of information and make decisions based on that and so on.
So there is that's a way to convey information to the routine via marks and quite, quite powerful.
So, yes, somebody asked me, oh, I forgot to bring your example.
Somebody said, OK. Barbara Beeton is here from a message.
She's trying to put out the the catalog of publications.
And this is one of those catalogs that's grown over the years and has all kinds of different printing formats.
And it's been quite a challenge to design the macros for it.
And one of the things that I think that that is a big index to it is over a thousand publications.
And they all want to each one has to wants to be in the index under a code name rather than rather than change that.
A lot of existing files. It's turned out that she wants to define a thousand different control sequences to read.
In a sense, she's going to define a thousand different control sequences and then read those all in when making the index.
Those will take. Tell you what page number the particular publication was on.
But the problem that she can she wrote to me about said, what about on every page?
He like to put a dollar sign in front of the prices on the first on the first thing on the page.
But that would not on any other publication.
So wherever the page breaks happened to occur, the first one on the page is supposed to have dollar signs in those.
You know, you have it there. Barbara Oh, good. Let me show you the problem.
Oh, this is this is. OK. So there is a dollar sign, you see, and then you don't have signs afterwards.
Next page doesn't have any dollar signs at all. Here's one. This is the problem.
How did this how to make that work. OK. And in the end, the answer frailest is doing two passes.
I don't know of any way to do that. Kind of a conditional thing in one part, but I think it's legitimate to do say some things in two passes.
The first pass to figure out where the big or the breaks are going to occur.
Then a person can just insert a few Egypt into the file knowing this, that that the page breaks are going to occur in that place,
because this is this is where we're combining all kinds of optimization at once.
And we can't we can't you know, the the change in the text might very well affect the place of the page break.
So you'll be in a vicious circle. In many cases. You have an idea how to solve them.
Is this the first is that I was supposed to appear at the top on each page?
No, it's it's in different places. No. OK. Can we take a look at this?
This one again, you see where mean it should be up there, but it's might be on the third line down.
What you mean. Yeah, I think if it's predictable you'll know where the column is going to be here.
I wanted on the second line right here, I want to after this know after a little preamble.
So yeah, it's up to could still get away with that.
I'm saying that there are that there are probably going to be problems maybe that
you might even think of a way to do it and you can work it out after class. But but there are there are going to be problems which which.
Two passes will be. We'll be at seven. Now, another thing could be done, in fact, is when she sends to a file,
she could send not only the page number where these where these are, but whether it was first on a page or not.
It would be possible to determine that, I believe, by by reading that file and figuring out where the which things are first on the page.
And then and then nothing would have to be changed. Any input file could all be done automatically.
You have a. Yeah.
This may be kind of naive because I haven't worked with tech for a while, but what happens in front of it in front of every single price.
You put a macro theme there and the output routine defines the macro name to be a dollar sign followed by the macro redefines itself to be nothing.
Right. Solution. That's what happens when you go when you get this. And that's what that's what she's done now.
And the reason is that the tech will read ahead and its vertical list until it finds the best possible place to break a page.
So it might be halfway into the next page before they call the output routine.
By that time, these these other things. Already been boxed and put away.
Jim. Jim. Jim, I worry about them.
Sighs If I ever trying something like this, you might be able to is a relative of the point about growth from yesterday's class.
I have the last word of what the coordinates are.
I don't know how to get that information in text source. You can think about this one to see if you can if it if you solve it.
You might get an acknowledgment from the next catalog public. I have some I have a lot more to cover today.
But there will be there will be cases then I think, where it's words meaningful to to assume that that person will will do trial setting.
And this is for for some complex jobs.
I would say this is since this and it doesn't cost that much computer time actually to get these trial settings and get the copies.
Then we're actually ahead by doing it that way, then by by doing something that's gonna be flaky and cost some other some other crashes.
Somebody know. Well, anyway, that's what that's the one problem that if people were saying what can't tech do?
And that's one that might not be able to do that, maybe we'll think another way.
Now, I got to tell you, the first solution end to this challenge.
Problem wants to use Mark's to. The second solution was my solution, which used inserts, top inserts.
And so what I did was, was after getting a line on a page,
if there was a if there was a new verse starting on that line, then a top insert would go in.
The top insert would be of some of some box that would that would set up the number in the margin.
OK. And the top and so would also have glue forward and aft.
And there would be a top step also specified which would separate the top insert from the from the from the text itself.
So I'm sitting there with with essentially these skip. And then a box on each box and then another V skip.
That's my top insert. And then I have the top step, which is another V skip.
And how I was allowed to fiddle with these with the parameters so that the.
So that if you plugged in what happens when there was no top insert,
when there was a top insert or when there were two top insert, the the everything we get positioned in the right way.
And you can check it out on the solution sheet that that it works.
It turns out that the the way things come out every time you do the the the calculation
to send something to the opera routine and to Reebok's it to me eight and 1/2 points,
it turns out that the glue is either zero with no one.
There are no top inserts or negative one fifth when there was one top insert or negative one when there were two, but always negative.
And so it'll always it'll always do that. That's right. So that would that was a way to to convey these these three things and get them to line up.
Right. Just by computing the the glue properly.
And it was a little interesting exercise in mathematics to figure out how to how to make that all check out the the people at BNR will.
We'll have to use a new version of Taxol before they try this, because the last Saturday when I was preparing my hand up for Monday,
I found out that the calculation of of depth of a page was incorrect in the old version of TAG have been incorrect for three years.
Nobody ever noticed in the presence of inserts. And it was very complicated where it where the text came in, in the insert came.
But what was the actual depth of that page? And that algorithm was fixed.
We actually tried to use those sorts. Unfortunately, our version of success would have tops up and pops up.
Oh, is it produces the new TVI, which we have nothing agreed that it would, David.
Yeah. So there is this problem with when we're talking about these things on the cutting edge
that that that they they are things that were not not as well understood a year ago.
So although tech has been remarkably stable. That was up until last Saturday.
This week, this week I put in seven different things because of just preparing this class and
rethinking things over and much more deep form than I'd ever been forced to do before.
So. So that's another reason why why it might not have been so easy to solve the challenge problem.
Now, the third solution to the challenge problem is, really is is is really fantastic.
And this one. And this is to convey. Information, the awkward routine by using the depth of the box sets.
OK, for this person reconfigured every time a new verse would come, any recompute, add a longer stretch with more depth.
OK. And so then the length of this of the of the depth of the box that goes the upper routine can now be can now be read essentially.
And then you can take. You can check it out and find out what it is. And then then branch to whatever routine you want.
And casher that deserves a gold star. I'm sorry to say it's too you know, it's really weird, but I've worked.
So that was the other solution to to it now. That's.
Who knows what people will think of next week. Yes.
Sounds could be used to sort of marks off sums. Could be a control oddly sent to the output file and wrote back.
Why is it that seems only happen when you actually cause output to go to the file or whatever output file it sends sends only comment output time,
because this was the this was important that we wanted for the information that sent out to depend on the on
the on the page where it's something appears rather than to depend on the place where it is in in the file.
Since tech is way ahead of itself on on on building pages before it decides to send something to the output routine,
we need some way to to to have it seems there would be an independent of this of this asynchronous process.
So so the idea of Marx was was intended to.
The first thing to counteract that, the second the second thing is send also evaluates counts.
At that time. So and so you want to know exactly what page something appears on therefore send.
It's not going to appear at the very moment of sending. Now, if someone wanted to send something instantaneously,
that would be another that would be another thing that could be added to attack
by just looking at the way the Senate works now and probably filling it in.
But there is a there is a provision in tech for extensions. These these extensions I hate to have to have to have anyone.
Right. I mean, anyone expect to use these extensions and then run this program in another place.
But but but there's a there's a separate module that makes it very easy to link in your own extensions into debt.
And some of the extensions that I that that people will think of them then maybe in 10 years we should we come by
with another version that we're a lot some of these extensions become become frozen into the into a real one.
But meanwhile, I'd like to know and we soon will have all versions of tech again in sync with each other.
And I tried not to put in every possible extension because there's no way to do that.
There's that word I could easily spend my life putting in another extension every month because someone will keep thinking of more things to do.
The first thing you learn when you start working on software is that everyone, every user has his own pet new thing to extent to the language.
So I try to hold the line.
And when it's something takes only three lines to like this mark in horizontal mode or something like that, then then I don't know.
Then I'm in a weak moment tonight and a day later I like stick it in but some sometime soon I
won't even do that because stability will be more important than than yet another new feature,
another patient email of the somehow the size of the program in tech has tends to be one
third to one fifth the size of of other typesetting programs that don't do as much.
And it's because of this paring things down, but still being able to to program the things that I know.
This idea about putting one line at a time is indicate one.
The main reason I wanted to show it to you just now is partly to open your eyes at all.
Other routines need not only have multiple columns, but they might have multiple lines,
but also to to indicate that if you had to write a simulator of somebody else's
paging mechanism that that didn't include the optimization of outbreaks or refills,
you could do it. All right. You can you can you can slow it back down to the level of other typesetting programs.
Bye bye. Programing your routines in this way. I originally I didn't know that that would be true.
Originally, I, I, I had an output routine that that was good enough to do the.
Yes, of the art of computer programing. And when I.
And after about two months, it occurred to me that maybe I'd be able to write one for the index also, which was double column format and.
And took me all afternoon. And at the end of the day, I was really delighted to find out like that without changing tack.
I was able to actually produce double column format in the index 14, and I had no idea originally that that it would be at that general.
And then as time has gone on, we've learned how to do almost incredible things in awkward routines.
Now, I've I've wanted to show you that this is a handout. Have you got the two page handout?
That two page handout is about balancing. And it shows it shows a a a possible solution to the problem of balancing copy.
Here was the output of the of the copy. These are.
Let's see. We don't have to focus up to see the letters. Just go zoom back so that we can see just the pages as they are.
OK. Now there's this there is a Grimm's fairy tale that we're using.
Another example is illustrated here in a two column format printed by this thing that was done when your hand out.
And this is a nice little this was the very first in the in Grimm's tales.
And if you want to read the story, go to the library and so on. Then I did it again.
And you see what the problem was to get the get the calm's balanced and then have a new title and then start over appropriately.
OK. Now in the second setting of this is exactly the same, only the title that's been has been restored to its original.
And the end of every paragraph is that one line loose.
So so each little paragraph in this is actually one line longer than than was previously.
And usually you see the way the end of the paragraph tends to be short.
But I didn't think I stretch. Well, now a weirdo line couldn't help it fixed.
There was no baselines given that in this particular example. So then the third one, this is two lines loose.
But you see, again, this this these macro, they're supposed to handle this balancing and restarting and getting going again.
The proper way is two lines loose. You get two rivers and a short paragraph.
And here on the last line, I made one of the lines so that it was only one line loose,
I believe, beliefs because there were even number of paragraphs,
something, or maybe it maybe it was one paragraph that couldn't be made, two lines loose without seeing times anyway.
You see, you also have the problem that there's an odd number of lines.
And so you have to balance it and you have to make sure that you get the extra extra line there.
OK. So that was the that was the problem.
And that this this this macro attempts to solve and I didn't give you the outlook,
but I gave you the input and the input and the source file had a I had a clear above title means, I guess, starting a page at the title.
And then I gave with the Frog King and I, I gave Jay PA 27.
That means so long, certain width of spaces at most three cubed, most three times the stretch ability.
So that means you go up to I think one M space at the worst. And then there was the beginning of the of the thing where I did poor man's small caps.
I did this caps the small caps, you know, hardway them right.
To put the I just take up a little higher. That's, you know, a little bit of I just came out like that.
So then then I said in this case I had to say, prepare somewhere near the end of the story.
I had to say, get ready. Now, there's a way around that. But this is the first of all, we have all the hyphens in this file.
It turned out because I had already built this file for lots of different tests on my paragraphing routine.
So I putting all the hyphens. Make sure that I work my hyphenation algorithm when my other experiments.
Now, at the end of the story, it says balance. OK. Then we do the same, the same thing.
This time sitting Jay way up and moves one and then do the same story again in balance.
And similarly, lose three. Oh, while I was for the very end of the story, I didn't lose three.
That was how I was able get an odd number of lines. And finally balance, then flush at the end.
So that was the that's the source there. The solution is on the previous page of the handout and how it actually works.
Well, the basic idea is that when you say prepare from that point on,
the resize has changed and tech will just gather along the text from that point on into one long, long list.
And then then at the end, you say balance. And at that point, it changes the Visayas back to the two.
It figures out how how long this this list. This page is that that it has has Bill.
And then it takes half of that and sets the resize to half.
Then then unbox is the text.
I'm sorry. It puts out a.
But the balance routine,
the output routine just saves us away and enough information for the routine outside the office routine to start to get to unbox.
This is Save the Way box and ends and get more information out into the output routine.
Daily routine itself can't include the unbox. The unbox instruction has to be has to be done outside the outside routine.
So the problem is to communicate from the outset routine to the non output routine thing.
Now it's time to run the box through. That's why I had this preparation step essentially.
And the balancing routine is done at a time, at a quiet time, at the end of the at the end of the story,
when we know that there is nothing else coming into the to the output routine.
OK. So so that's a no. The unboxing sends everything back through into the page again.
The baseline calculation between the the calculations of glue between lines is not redone, but the calculation at the very top of a page is done.
The calculation to get the top baseline on a page correct is is carried out.
The stretch in shrink doesn't change in the glue. It's the amount of space, though, between lines has already been has already been determined.
When this thing was set, first it's unboxed the vertical is just sent right back to the page built again after it gets to the V size,
then it then hits another output routine.
Albertine saves a little left column and and the next one saves away the right column, after which the V sizes is adjusted again.
So that we're ready to. So that that that the the the parts of the page that's been done at the top has been stashed away.
This part, for example, has been stashed away in some box.
And that and a number saying how how big the current page is has been reset so that it's the size of the remaining page.
Then the same program works again. And this box is normally empty, that box of other things that have been saved from other time.
So to put it put the title on, it just makes the V size a little bit smaller.
The basic idea then was to use Unbox to feed the text through twice.
Now we've had even while the ideas where we can read the text through three and four times, it turns out that when you're in restricted vertical mode,
the E the Egypt does nothing like you could do a top insert containing an edict in there and get
inserted into the top and nothing happens because it was born in restricted or vertical mode.
Ejectors is ignored as it goes into the list, though. So when you unbox it and put it and put the unbox thing in vertical mode,
that Egypt is now going to force call on the output machine and get back control into the output routine.
And so base by sprinkling Egypt's around in your in in things you can like after every footnote you could,
including Egypt now would trigger an output, a call, an output routine.
And that would be. That's another way to to get control back and forth.
And these these routines essentially communicate with each other by slaving away in control variables, any state information that's necessary.
And it's not it's not like alcohol, but it's it's not much different from a lot of love of hardware routines.
And and it's humanly understandable with with with even possible to document the programs and write them in a way that looks almost structured.
I didn't do that in this particular handoff.
So the balance routine has what has a feature that one of the things that, you know, it fits on this on this one page.
But actually a lot of the code is is just to divide by two.
I believe I did a program, the division by two in here, a recursive division by two where bisect your team.
Oh, okay. Yeah. No, that's not that's not really taking. Yeah I see that.
Yeah. This, this doesn't take much space but this is that this is a division, the division by two routine increasing count,
seven by the number of lines that are actually to be used in each case because there was no glue,
it was gonna be difficult to to decide that the V side should be exactly half of the of the proper amount.
If that wouldn't work,
that wouldn't work because it would come out to be a line and a half and then there would be problem just feeding the thing back with unbar.
So. So now if this is not if you were dealing with another kind of text, then then where you expect there would be glue there.
For example, you put glue in your base, mindscape, you would put a glue in your PA, skip a little bit of glue.
There doesn't hurt, although a baseline skipp, if it goes up by about two tenths of a point or three tenths of a point, it becomes noticeable, but.
About one tenth of a point, it's it's not that easy to sue. It doesn't make quite so much visual pollution.
It's called carding because they used to stick in cardboard between the lines in order to make the pages come come that size this.
So you put some glue in the baseline, skip, you put it in, make part in the power skip phase between paragraphs has turned out to be a fairly,
fairly good way to high water lines and things like that.
Then then this kind of balancing work.
Now, this isn't the definitive solution of bouncing.
It's just one approach to balancing to show you how it's a whole basis for other four other solutions.
And friends from BNR have have indicated a nice a nice way to get around the problem.
What about glue that got that disappear?
OK, so. So let me see. They they were setting they were solving the balancing problem in this way.
At the time a balance instruction comes along, there's been no preparation.
And so the ultra routine is faced with two boxes of maybe one from the left column and one from a partially complete right column.
And they offer routine, wants to wants to take that and and get and, you know, put the boxes back together again.
Unbox that and send it to the page builder with the proper size for the for the balancing.
However, what if this what if a break occurred just before I knew subheading.
And so there was a there was a skip of twelve points that got deleted at the break between the end of the first column and the beginning.
The second consulate, the subheading would appear right at the top of the second column where it should.
And so the question is, how could the awkward routine know when it stuck,
when it puts these two boxes together again to get them to get them to work correctly?
Well, you can't do that just with stress,
because the cause because actually we wanted that glue to disappear if the two columns were not going to be balanced.
And so they have a nice solution to this. They did it with Marks. One of the things that the mark will put out on a line that will go out,
I would say it would be saying that the thing that's coming next is is a subheading, an indication of what is coming next.
And the upper routine knows what format is being used and it can restore the glue that was that was there for a subheading.
Unfortunately, this didn't work last week, again, because there was a rule in tech that when you destroy glue at the end of a page,
you just continue reading through glues and penalties until you get to something else and the glues and penalties disappear.
But when you got to a mark node, it stopped the clock. And then glue after the mark note would still appear on the top of the next slide.
So that rule has now been changed so that when you at the top of a page,
you can have marks and sends and inserts and it does not affect the calculation of the of the top baseline.
So the first the first real box or rule that gets on the page is going to have the counting is going to get the proper top baseline calculated.
And before it was almost that way, unless there had been a send or a mark or an insert beforehand, then the top baseline would would get applied.
That wouldn't be applied the toughest. I was only applied when it was the very first thing going on the page and glues and penalties were ignored.
So this will now be a nice a nice solution to that for that problem to use to use a mark to spit to help the output routine.
No, if it's if he wants to do this kind of complicated balancing.
So the state of the output routine world then,
is that that this this will always be a a I believe an area where where the most difficult to fathom routines will are possible to write.
And the alternative would be to write them in some in in in some ALGOL like language that
would be that would be embedded within the typesetting system or something like that.
It looks like it would be more difficult to make this that kind of thing portable.
So. So I guess I'm resigned to the fact that I'll put routines will be arcane.
After all, we can we can get some fun.
I mean, one of the problems about microcomputers has been that that we hate to admit how much fun it is to to to to code in octal again.
I mean, Hexa. But at least it's not stylish to do things like that.
Still, we can. Yes, people. People also enjoy playing duplicate bridge and things.
And that's not that structure. It's a lot of different rules.
And so I think there is something in human minds that that enjoys a bit of a bit of our art, our candidacy, whatever the word.
OK. I've run out of time almost.
But I can answer your last question if anyone has a last question.
Richard. Frank, I was just wondering again, when exactly a send is sent to OK.
What happens is a send sits in whatever listed, whatever list it was inserted, Massimo, horizontal and vertical mode.
And it and it just sits there even is as invisible as a strike.
It doesn't have any size. Then the all the boxes will contain it.
Finally, something is sent to the output routine and it's actually for example,
somebody is going through these, all these lists and saying, now let's make the Dover print the right thing.
At that point, the send is interpreted.
Now, this is after the upper routine is finished. Its work, the author routine has gone on and complete and completed its job.
And men. And when when when the upper routine is done, it's tech gives an error message if page hasn't been looked at at all.
So if it's helpful, if he didn't look at page at all, Tech says that's a little strange and then it gives you a warning about it.
It seems that page at least been gobbled up by the up routine. But it does.
But then it looks and sees if this vertical list that the upper routine has has constructed is empty or not.
If it's if it's if it's empty, then tech assumes that they are operating as just saving for a later day, incidentally.
There's no way to go the other way and have two pages about Puddicombe. Come on, one eject.
But anyway, if it's not empty, then then it goes to the to the DVR file afterwards.
During which time the sends are are taking place.
The idea was that I'm going along and I have a send on a page which is sending count zero or cowhorn or something else.
Right. And then it goes on to the next page because it hasn't decided where to break the page.
And I have a best count. And then after that, it decides to break the page.
What is going to be sent by Sandy? That's right. So that's why we wanted to send to do it that way.
And because of most and the most important uses, it was for table of contents and indexes.
Now that the the other thing I wanted to mention is that those is output routine will advance the page count.
And so that they have actual value of count one at the time.
Is the at the time to send occurs is not the page number that knew that it was on, but the page number of the following page.
And the typical way to do that is to.
Is not to output count zero but to count. But I count one and say set count.
Can we have this on the screen. Said count one to count zero for example.
And then advance can't zero at the end of your output routine. And then the the indexed macro will use count one.
And so then that will be the page that it actually appeared on your marks versus demarks work the same way that if you mark.
No, the mark Mark. Well, Mark will expand counts at that time that they're at the upper routine is looking at them.
One more question. This has to be the last one, though. And the question is, could X just be used in a send?
What if I if I would use an X F when I was sending to two to expand the count at the time was sending?
Then that would give me the count. That would give me the the value of count B.
That might not correspond to the actual page on which the thing appears.
If I spent my expanded it out before I send it off.
Very well. You've all been quite an inspiration to me this week and I hope also I was able to convey one or two things that that you like.